hey
community ich bin ja gerade in chemnitz
und mega gefährlich was hier abgeht
überall straßenschlachten draußen aber
er ich gehe da raus für euch bringt die
aktion es scheißegal jetzt online update
keepers instagram war deine erste
synthetische erste storia aufgebraucht
war gut von soja und sogar gelacht ich
habe keine angst ist meist chemnitz
wovor ich angst
naja so einrichten warum ist gemacht ich
habe einfach die letzten zwei wochen nur
also durchaus herzlich interviews von
hans-georg maßen gelesen und jetzt denke
ich eigentlich ist einfach eine ganz
normale stadt ist nix da hinten könnte
erhalten
[Musik]
wir brauchen rechte bringen
wir brauchen dringend rechte vors mikro
haben sie rechte getroffen wir suchen
recht wir wollen jetzt auch ein paar
recht wo sind die nation wie lange
stehen sie schon hier seit 20 minuten
jetzt hier und sind noch in keiner heads
jahren verrecke tonne sind überrascht
sind sie recht natürlich nicht dazu
schade
wir sind zum ersten mal in chemnitz und
wollen unsere wähler ist ein fehler ja
nach chemnitz kam noch mal kann man
öfters kommen ja aber warum nicht nur
wegen den nischel nicht deswegen ist das
ist ein mittel das kopfschütteln
das ist der level das ist unglücklich
aber was heißt er weist den kopf nach
der kopf her ganz ein
wie fühlen sie sich hier gut sicher
manchmal unwohl und wohl nicht das heißt
ja dann immer jahr chemnitz chemnitz ist
nicht gerade bund sondern einseitig und
ich glaube die mehrheit setzt sich doch
mehr für das bunte ein menschen nach
hautfarbe oder ähnliches zu beurteilen
ob das jetzt ein guter mensch ist oder
ein schlechter mensch finde ich
grundsätzlich schon moralisch sprechen
und stadtbad was da ist da sehen sehen
sie also schon relativ wenig deutsche
noch daran die afg wird ja hier
wahrscheinlich stärkste kraft werden wie
finden sie das
da muss man mal in berlin zeigen dass
das dass diese so nicht weitermachen
können
jetzt sind sie ja chemnitzer ja und ich
war jetzt letztes jahr nicht dabei dass
irgendwo ich gern mal von ihnen wissen
wie war das denn mit der hetzjagd da
gibt es nur diesen kurzen ausschnitt da
hat keiner den gefangen hat keiner den
auf den eingeprügelt es hinterher
gelaufen so was tut jeden normalen beim
fußball wenn du siehst wie diese die die
sich daran machen
das ist gang und gäbe ich war nicht
fehlen
du hast nicht will aus dem einfachen
grund weil ich in unsere politik einfach
jeden vertrauen aber findest du nicht
dass es eben parteien gibt die mehr für
freiheit stehen als für andere und zu
sagen okay dann ist jetzt nicht 100
prozent meine batterie aber ich gehe zur
wahl
ich nehme dieses recht war man sagt okay
dann werde ich aber jetzt weiß was ich
die grünen die erste kleinere möbel das
kleinere übel
das findest du nicht dass man das tun
sollte einer demokratie aus dem
einfachen grund wenn dann sollte mich
eine partei zu 100 prozent überzeugen
wenn sie heute irgendwas gegen die gegen
mainstream sagen ja dann sind zugleich
ein rechtsradikaler bin ich nachher
ordner rechtsradikaler statt mich dann
ja in wir haben auch welche gesucht
ich bin immer noch nicht das ist was ist
denn wenn jetzt schon ja ja ja wir
müssen das land ich schlag vor
dorfchemnitz nirgendwo war die afg so
stark wie bei der bundestagswahl in
sachsen fast 50 prozent gewählt und nur
16 leute haben die grünen gewählt 16
[Musik]
hallo wirklich einfach fragen stellen
entschuldigung
die kurzen
[Musik]
das will ja niemals richtig mit uns
reden vielleicht ja sie sie könnte mit
uns eventuell kohls ja auch nicht auch
nicht der herr bock hast du die grünen
gewählt
vielleicht haben wir das anschleichen
ich komme von links du vielleicht hast
du afd gewählt das führt aber auch
zunächst keine antworten
das ist die antwort
[Musik]
er ist wieso muss man vorsichtig
vorsichtig weil sie die ledigen center
vertreten lassen und dann sind gespannt
nein das machen die leute meist schon
selber 16 leute haben in dorfchemnitz
die grünen gewählt
kennt man die sie sind mussten die
inzwischen umziehen
also ich kenn ich persönlich nicht und
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass linien
ziehen müssen
als wir ihn kenne ich nur die alena
bernburg die von kobolden spricht und da
hat sie sich im prosieben und
disqualifiziert von ihren sachen
wenn es kitschig klingt den haarweg
fleisch noch gar kein deutsches volk
kennt
aber was wenn es zwischen nicht so gut
was gefällt ihnen an der fdp frau merkel
hat gesagt meine politik ist
alternativlos und ich bin der meinung
der meinung bin ich nicht ich bin für
eine alternative für merkels politik
mehr service stützen nicht hast schon
ganz schön anstrengend aber es gibt ja
nix kein supermarkt
andererseits ist es wahlkampf wird
irgend politiker geben da sind wurst aus
ich glaube auch bratwurst grillt klappt
schon mal gut wie gerät man die afd
erst einmal muss man mit praktischen
dingen anfangen deswegen ist schon mal
ein guter versuch und ansonsten bleibt
nichts anderes übrig als seine eigenen
themen immer wieder zu sagen und dafür
zu sorgen dass die leute aus der filter
blase des internets heraus kommt und die
realität sehen so wie sie ist wenn die
als stärkste partei wird macht es in
sachsen als bundesland aufzugeben und
zum beispiel an russland zu verkaufen
nein es wird auch nicht passieren weil
wir sehr dafür arbeiten und es immer
mehr menschen gibt die verstanden haben
dass die situation mehr als ernst ist
und jetzt es darauf ankommt dass alle
vernünftigen menschen zur wahl gehen
damit genau das nicht passiert also
darüber haben sie als sie mit putin
besprochen haben nicht verhandelt
sachsen gerade berger wir gesprochen und
wir haben uns eigentlich das ist ein
hervorragendes spiel das war die creme
hat er ja schon und dann noch sachsen
dazu wie möchten sie ihre bratwurst
dunkel oder hell somit eine gute bräune
typisch 6 des zdf so unentschieden
sie wollen auf keinen fall mit der fdp
koalieren gilt das nur bis zum wahlabend
oder das ganze ja meine tiefe
überzeugung weil sie müssen wissen ich
bin ein volksvertreter aus ihrer sicht
und da hört der spaß auf
aus fdp sicht jetzt 18 setzt weiß kurz
irritieren sie also aus meiner sicht
sind sie nur ein würstchen grillen was
freuen sie sich dann schon darauf dass
sie vielleicht mit den grünen koalieren
müssen nein das ist glaube ich eine
ehrliche andere vereine eine ehrliche
frage aber dann liegt hoch vor
nein also mit anderen worten gibt es
hier nicht michaels kennt offen also
sachs ist nicht eu land sachsen muss
fleisch land bleiben ist fleisch land
genau das ist mal ein guter slogan würde
ich sogar cdu wählen sachs muss fleisch
land bleiben da hätten sie mich ist
fleisch isst fleisch land ist weil sie
glauben noch dran sie schaffen es ja
auch ohne die grünen ja ohne die a f dr
ohne die linkspartei mit gebratenen
würstchen wo es trost und sozusagen viel
er hat den ganzen abend hier das
arbeiten von ihr dummes zeug jetzt muss
auch mal gut sein
[Musik]